rob it's finally here
what's here we can play cyberpunk in
third freaking person oh
my god show it to me this mod is brought
to you by joe backer
and it is uh something else
damn it's like a fallout game i know
right i those are the kind of those are
the vibes i got
we can change the camera angle here we
can look at my character from the front
look at my character from a little
closer we can offset the camera
i'm going to do it here i think here's
pretty good
uh this seems pretty fine though right
look at this
not bad high knees you got high knees
you look a little stiff i'm a little
stiff
all right straight up you are walking
like jar jar binks
no no mr stay musical
and pinks do that again better than here
than the core
uh it's about to get weird though
oh the torso is perfectly still
it's kind of got a similar effect to
like those those like head cams that
became popular a few years ago you know
what i mean oh yeah totally
you're just you're just completely
locked to one way over
the body check this out okay you look
you look like you lost some of your
torso
that's the slide it's a good old slide
that gives me
that looks really painful
it's like falling off a motorcycle on
the highway dude
what your arm is
i wish so one of the issues is that when
i go into camera mode
it reverts it reverts everything back
because i would love to take a picture
like this
dude it looks like you're sticking
yourself up
give me all your money me
oh god i want to find some enemies here
we can
yeah oh you're gonna fight
i think there's some by the beach i'm
already crying okay here we go
oh god
yeah aiming down sights just doesn't
really work so i figured out the best
weapons to use
are these the ones where you don't have
to aim
oh i died oh they're all every
every position was a different level of
deformity
oh well so is that your hat oh no that's
those are your that's inside your my
teeth your teeth
oh oh your head's gone and now my head's
gone this is the glitch that i kept
running into
after i die my head would disappear is
that because of the mod or just
it's because of the mod yeah yeah okay
it's something with the mod
but we're gonna let it run because it
looks funny all right
down to the beach i'm not gonna lie i
had uh last
last week i had a really bad uh back
problem
and i'm i feel like mentally i'm like re
reliving a lot of it like
like my spine is my my spine is
dealing with some flashbacks looking at
this oh
[Laughter]
imagine this thing just running at you
being like all right
i would i would rethink my life
oh my god
yeah things where you don't really have
to aim like shotgun smart weapons seem
to be the way to go with this
the extended arm what is some of it i'm
trying to like
process
i'm trying to make sense of it and i
think it's not
worth doing but it's like
you know like like stability like with
camera movements
like what what why is your left why is
your
left knee up
i have no idea yeah it's just like
like this game clearly was not made for
third person in the least
like it's i i think what this mod shows
us
is that there is a lot of work that
would need to be done for this game to
work properly in third mer
third person and i know the modder is
this is a work in progress mod so the
modder plans on doing more eventually
but i think a lot of people yeah here we
go i think a lot of people expected it
would just be like a flip of the switch
right like you hit a switch and then all
of a sudden you see your character but
it's kind of interesting to see how like
that's not how first person games are
made like they're not made with the same
same uh uh proportions i guess you'd
normally expect
right like all that matters all that
matters is what's in your peripheral for
first person
everything else goes out the door dude i
love
your all biceps man this is
this is an arm day
you're so stiff now do you get what's
going on
because i still don't a little bit
for a second when you switched your gun
or did something it looked like you
could
it like opened up inside oh maybe it was
your red gun i thought it looked like
like the innards of your
body i just look like i'm rag dolling
through here but when you sprint
it like eliminates part of your like
stomach
all right back to no head it looked like
your head was there for a second i don't
know
it's definitely what's up you're not
there
you can't like interact with anything in
the third person either which is strange
oh no i can there oh there it is
maybe if you look look at yourself in
the mirror it'll trigger
like it's got to bring your head it
really looks like
your head imploded into your body
i don't know what i'm looking at here
[Laughter]
there we go my head's back your head's a
vampire
no that doesn't make sense reverse first
vampire
what on earth
all right let's stop looking here all
right
here we go there we go we got the head
back don't
don't i won't yeah i won't shoot anyone
this time when you switch from first to
third
your head definitely pops in for a
second yeah like load it in for like a
frame or two
i think it's because like that's the
thing you customize
for your body like the rest of it isn't
like like you're not
morphing it at all it's like that's what
it looks like yeah yeah this part
call elevator oh i did it sick
this the second jump is really stiff
oh a little tripped a little bit there
do crouch
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
oh
he doesn't care all right let's
let's do what everyone's thinking yeah
where's your cute little
get yourself to a little r-e-l-a-x-x-x
show me what those hands can do
if it cuts to first person it's just
gonna be really awkward
oh no it doesn't
but these are my options here
[Laughter]
i'm not hearing anything too that's
probably much better
yeah i'm hearing it sick well thanks
jake
uh i guess we'll have to uh you know
here's to hoping they uh add some
patches to this mod i'm sure they'll
get there um or maybe not maybe this is
what you get
yeah it's hard to say this mod is uh was
created by gel backer by the way
um you can find it on nexus mods we're
gonna leave a link in there you do
also need the cyberpunk engine tweak mod
as well it's all super easy to install
if you wanna try it out
um but yeah that's a bit of cyberpunk in
third person as you can see
the game as of now is not really built
for it
uh but yeah like you were saying maybe
one day uh
maybe one day this model gets some
updates and v will
look like a human being yeah here's to
that i mean you know it's it's
it's like any new newly released pc game
it'll take some times i'm sure
people are diligently cracking away at
solving this
really huge problem but uh yeah if you
want a couple laughs this is this is
definitely worth it i got mine
all right we'll see y'all next time see
you guys
you